hello there I'm gone I'm done where the
slo-mo dice and today we're going to use
a very fast camera to look at some
underwater explosions
can use these little bangers and 1000s
stick them in with a float so they
source it in the middle because they
actually just rise to the surface of
yeah we want to try this before but with
the old camera wasn't fast enough
yeah we're trying to film about 2500
frames a second today we're gonna do
28,000 frames a second so that's really
open our slo-mo eyes into what's really
happening and maybe even if we're
feeling cheeky they're a little bit slow
looking forward to this looking forward
to it
I'm gonna go get a lighter alright don't
try to hurt me that now the explosive
creates a little sphere so I'm gonna
focus on where the front of that sphere
is gonna be and not on the Banger itself
so at the beginning we'll probably be
out of focus but come into focus
hopefully
Oh
good
that's cool
a little funk smells good ready that's
very cool oh it's like the the light
comes back as it comes in it's like all
the explosive mess is being recompressed
into pee I can't hit expose well really
doc just so you can see more detail in
the explosion
that first one is pretty bright
all right cut it close the deal hand
there it's actually quite a long way of
fuse inside to see ya if I swear your
hand is on it when the fuse hit the
banger that one little moment in time is
so cool that last was such a small
amount of time I should the banger one
little bang oh there was a frame in
there to look cool
we are now at 512 by 320 pixels which is
shockingly bad sort of lower than
standard def bad but the upside is for
120,000 frames a second so slight issue
with the filming in high speed and
having to split all right I do not only
you in high speed so everything's dark
but I'm also stopping down the lens so
much that this is what I can see on the
screen if you're struggling to see it's
absolutely nothing so this will be trial
and error as in the exact framing
Oh
no idea if we got that the thing is that
the refresh rate on that screen is so
bad I didn't see anything on it so I
have no idea whether we got it yet
struggling to find it it's only a split
second it's not the amount of footage
you've selected oh we got it
awesome that's Wow
[Music]
[Music]
very cool I was wicked very very cool so
it seems like we're never going to be
able to see the entire explosion in full
detail we're only going to be able to
see either just the very beginning or
not the beginning and some of the rest
of it so we've taken different exposures
we've got like different stages of the
explosion there correctly exposed okay
so I'm actually quite interested to see
what the surface of the water does as
the explosion happens so we're gonna
position one a few inches under and do
it a sort of more normal frame rate
what's normal frame rate that's not
normal frame rate on this camera this
[Music]
nice
very nice
[Music]
[Music]
well the tank survives another video I
don't know what we're gonna have to do
to get rid of this thing it's oppressive
yeah although the ink one wasn't really
pushing here yeah that was crazy I love
seeing those cavitation balls I'm not
sure if it is just to vacuum or whether
the reaction from the bag actually puts
air into there but it it closes in again
and sort of reignites whatever is in
there it is cool it's also interesting
how because the fuse contains its own
source of oxygen even if it's underwater
you don't need to worry about it it will
still go so cool I love doing establish
ridiculous frame rates hopefully you
enjoyed that video I found that when
fascinating feel free to follow us on
Twitter subscribe we got the second
channel for behind the scenes and we got
much for the t-shirt gun so I hopefully
will see you in the next video
your dip oh oh
always a smell that no one caught us
nicely with in it what you
okay but that would look quite cool in
slow-mo now you tell me back up just do
that again